- Hi, I'm Trixie Mattel.
- And I'm Katya.
- And today we're gonna be
cutting these people's throats.
- Oh! Hair, hair!
- Oh, hair.
- Hair, hair.
- You know what? I'm not into it.
Never mind. (laughter)
No, today we're gonna be cutting
these people some slack, ladies.
I have an advantage here because
I went to a beauty school, and--
- Mama, I went to art
school! Shut your mouth.
- But listen to get into this shit, bitch!
(laughter)
Three-quarters through beauty school
I had to drop out to go do Drag Race
so now for the rest of my life
I gotta hear that
fuckin' song from Grease.
- What Grease song?
Why do you like musicals so much?
- Grease Lightning, what do you think?
Beauty School Dropout!
You know, you could play
Harry Potter in a porn.
(they laugh)
- Oh, you totally could.
- Believe me, bitch.
Oh my God, style trend alert!
Wire-rimmed glasses, bitch.
- Yeah, yeah. Oh my God!
- Yeah.
- You have actually stunning hair.
- That's very sweet, thank you.
- How do you spell your name?
- Uh, K-Y-L-E.
- I love...you know, I've had not one,
not two: fifteen boyfriends named Kyle.
- So I'm gonna give myself a bang trim.
Which is a very bad idea. (Trixie laughs)
This is a very bad idea.
- You look like a baby
but you have gray hair.
Are you a Benjamin Button?
- Um...not that I know of yet, but--
- Don't lie! Are you a
fuckin' Benjamin Button?
- How old are you for real?
- 24.
- Grays at 24, bitch? You are a stud!
- Oh, I know what we can do! Hold on.
So we're gonna take three locks
of our hair and sell 'em online.
- In beauty school they taught us
you don't work in the beauty industry,
you work in the self-esteem industry.
So how do you feel right now?
- I feel very good, thank you.
- See?
- I'm gonna take it from the bottom.
Are you okay with that?
- Yes.
- How do you take it,
from the bottom? Honey.
- Ohhhh!
- Sounds like me at
Long Beach Pride, honey.
(Katya laughs)
Honey...
Do you know what I did
when I got on Drag Race?
The next day I went into beauty school,
packed up everything and
left, didn't tell anyone.
And hair-cutting is stressful!
- It's extremely difficult.
She is an idiot, and you're getting
your hair cut by an idiot.
(Trixie mumbles)
My makeup is lazy?
- No, you make it look, like, so easy.
- Oh.
(they laugh)
- I just like shaving heads.
Do you know when I cut my own hair
I kneel on the floor in a hotel--
- "I just love shaving heads."
- Trump's America. (sprays, gasps)
- I dare you.
- I have to take
a piece off.
- I dare you.
- Because you did this to me.
- Can I take your eyebrows off?
- Girl, my dad's a karate master.
I would waste you.
- I guess you wasted your life,
you can waste mine too.
(Katya laughs)
Do you have a boyfriend?
- Me, no.
(sustained spraying noise)
- You know that my adherence and
my commitment to beauty is so severe
that I don't have the heart to
fuck up your beautiful
hair, do you know that?
- Thank you.
- You need to wake up tomorrow
and get on your gross, dirty knees
and say to God or whomever,
"Thank you, Yahweh, or...
"whatever, for this
gorgeous head of hair,"
which is not thinning anytime soon,
and I mean, that
hairline's gonna stay put.
- Thank you.
- Who do you think is
prettier? Me or Katya.
- Uh, gentle reminder that there is
only one correct answer to this question.
- Gentle reminder there's a fuckin'
mechanical razor next to
your neck. (they laugh)
- Can we take this off of you?
I feel like you were a victim of a crime.
(they laugh)
(objects clatter to the floor)
Oh my God, oh my, it's starting again!
- Things happen in the salon.
Now Kyle, when you go to a salon
what kind of service, do you like
something really, like, in and out
or do you want something really luxurious
where they rub your hands and shit?
- Um, you know, usually
it's the in and out option.
- In and out option.
(Kyle laughs)
You really know me.
- So I want, like, something
super silky and straight
but also really bouncy,
curly and voluminous.
- You know, when I was
little, Kyle, I had a mullet
and I asked my mom why she didn't cut it
and she said she didn't have the heart to.
So she just let part of it grow
because she wanted some hair to
be, like, virgin from when I was a baby.
So, bitch, I had like--
- What?! Are you serious?!
- Oh, bitch, I had like--
- Preservation of the past?
- A lower back rat-tail running through
the woods of Wisconsin
like a fuckin' raccoon.
Melissa Joan Hart followed me on Twitter.
Why do you think so, Kyle?
- Um...
- Yeah, I'm serious, I have no idea why.
Well, I saw her on the Hollywood Medium
and she's very Christian, so I thought,
"Why does she care about me?"
- Oh.
- I though, Hollywood Medium?
Honey, in Hollywood I'm a 4X, honey.
I'm fully quitting drag and finding
the nearest Great Clips
and just getting my life.
(Kyle laughs)
- So with Eunice what I did here was
we played it safe but
we also did it dirty.
We had a moment, we
shared some common goals,
we learned a few things about each other,
and we just created a
priceless piece of art
that we will now sell on the internet,
for probably, like, 300 bucks.
Oh, yeah, where is it?
- It's right on your head.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh, it's very nice!
- Do you hate it?
- No, I love it!
- Are you lying to me?
- No, I love it. I love it.
Thank you so much.
- Are you lying to me?
- No, I'm not lying.
- He is not lying! Aah!
- The Trixie and Katya show debuts
on November 15th on Viceland.
- If you like the homeless, haircuts,
and trips to Hoboken, join us
on November 15th on Viceland.
- Yes, God. Honk honk!
Alright, that's it,
thank you, goodbye! Yay!
(peppy music)